I have heard so much hype around cottage
cheese ice cream I have a huge Sweet
Tooth and I wanted to try something with
it to see if I can make a more filling
dessert so I'm trying cottage cheese
fudgesicles two cups of cottage cheese
my favorite protein powder and then I
just used a blender I didn't need a food
processor for this freeze it and let's
see they look beautiful the texture is
there but how do they taste does it
really taste like ice cream
cottage cheese is a little salty so make
sure you're using a protein powder with
a lot of sweetness to cut that salt I
like it a lot the texture is really good
I will really enjoy these